port of us all I'm sure the nation will
join me in assuring you that what you do
is appreciated and every hour of your
hard work brings us closer to a return
to more normal times I also want to
thank those of you who were staying at
home thereby helping to protect the
vulnerable and sparing many families the
pain already felt by those who have lost
loved ones together we are tackling this
disease and I want to reassure you that
if we remain united and resolute then we
will overcome it I hope in the years to
come everyone will be able to take pride
in how they responded to this challenge
and those who come after us will say the
britons of this generation were as
strong as any that the attributes of
self-discipline of quiet good-humoured
resolve and a fellow feeling still
characterize this country the pride in
who we are is not a part of our past it
defines our present and our future the
moments when the United Kingdom has come
together to applaud its care and
essential workers will be remembered as
an expression of our national spirit and
it's symbol will be the rainbows drawn
by children across the Commonwealth and
around the world we have seen
heartwarming stories of people coming
together to help others be it through
delivering food parcels and medicines
checking on neighbors or converting
businesses to help the relief effort and
those self isolating may at times be
hard many people of all faiths and of
none are discovering that it presents an
opportunity to slow down pause and
reflect in prayer or meditation
it reminds me of the very first
broadcast I made in 1940 helped were my
sister we as children spoke from here at
Windsor to children who had been
evacuated from their homes and sent away
for their own safety today once again
many will feel a painful sense of
separation from their loved ones
but now as then we know deep down that
it is the right thing to do while we
have faced challenges before this one is
different this time we join with all
nations across the globe in a common
endeavour using the great advances of
science and our instinctive compassion
to heal we will succeed and that success
will belong to every one of us we should
take comfort that while we may have more
still to endure better days will return
we will be with our friends again we
will be with our families again we will
meet again but for now I send my thanks
and warmest good wishes to you all